quelques débris de voiture sur le bord
de la route de la sueur répandus sur la
chaussée des marques de peinture et une
trace de pneus mis en évidence pour les
besoins de l'enquêté
c'est tout ce qui restait de l'accident
ce matin le maire de montcenis est venu
sur les lieux pour tenter de comprendre
ce qui a pu se passer
ce qui est surprenant c'est que personne
mais freinée justement c'est on a
l'impression que les deux voitures se
sont rentrés dedans sans rien éviter
sens c'est bizarre à la mairie de
montcenis chez les drapeaux ont été mis
en berne trois jeunes tués dans
l'accident était de cette petite ville
de 2000 habitants où tout le monde se
connaît je connaissais bien sûr les
jeunes de montcenis 1 qui sont des
jeunes des jeux ne sert de des bongo ce
sans aucun problème qui revenait d'une
petite soirée je crois même pas d'une
soit il en va d'un petit restaurant un
jeune
et le fils du président du football-club
anti-chinois donc quelqu'un de très
connu à montcenis un qui est dans la
peine aujourd'hui bien sûr dont les
parents sont en état de choc bien sûr et
on attend d'en savoir davantage à 23
heures hier soir la violence de
l'accident entre les deux véhicules a
fait sept victimes de 20 à 25 en cinq
tués sur le coup
un autre peu après avoir été pris en
charge par les secours
un jeune homme est toujours entre la vie
et la mort à l'hôpital du creusot
on est plus habitué des accidents sur
des airs c'est rare des accidents de
route mais impliquant un tel nombre de
victimes sur cette route c'est
absolument rarissime
l'enquète devra déterminer les
circonstances de cette collision
toujours est il que les habitants aux
alentours affirme que c'est le troisième
accident ici en trois mois